every night I crime yourself to sleep
like nothing made me happy nothing
what a fighter I believe I promise here
to fight it was me father who taught me
how to punch and at 12 13 years old
that's a powerful tool to show a kid
finding out that your brother was gay
being a pivotal moment why from their
mid-90s it wasn't cool to be gay and
black that's when I'd say the fight and
take sheep
brutalize my body cannibalize my own
body there's five nights that I've had
that I can't remember anything that
Shield you put up to help you to survive
I'm guessing it's not serving you
value to hey nil one of the things I
will never forget is the raw emotion
that came out of you after you won that
fight you know people look at you and
think you're a success story they look
at the money you've got to look at the
scenario and the setup you've got but
ultimately are you happy
are you happy
so without further Ado I'm Stephen
Bartlett and this is the Diary of a CEO
I hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
Tony
from reading your book and a lot of the
things that you've said over the years
one of the things that really stood out
to me because I think it's been front of
mine because a few guests have said this
to me over the last couple of weeks is I
was a product of my environment and your
early environment was waverty in
Liverpool yeah
take me back to that environment and
tell me what it was about that
environment that
shaped who you went on to be and who you
are today
I am a product of my environment and and
I say that and the way I get to that is
because it's no coincidence I'm a
fighter I was just but I believe I'll
put on this here to fight it's something
that I enjoyed something that I like
it's something that I'm not afraid of
fighting doesn't it never scared me it
never bothered me and
I think that's a bit weird to be honest
but it's just me I can't change who I am
and uh the environment I was raised in
definitely helped producer you know from
being
a kid at the age of 10 me old man leaves
home he's gone and then at that age me
little brother at that age is about six
or seven me two Elder Brothers one I'd
moved out and the other one was on the
verge of finishing school
so the Elder one who finishes school
then goes on to further education he
goes to University so we keep moving on
over a few years
and then once I hit
13 14 it's quite apparently younger
brother's gay and then that's when I'd
say the fight and take shape and things
take shape so
so you said your dad left home when you
were 10. yep
how come
yeah
to the top and bottom of it yeah
and got caught basically a fantastic
father but you know it was carrying on
broke my mum's ass and was gone yeah so
a product of most men to be honest but
uh that was the reason me that was gone
so he was carrying on he had an affair
with some Scot bag of a woman who knew
he was married with four kids and
yeah he just he let us the thing in
between in his pants rule his head and a
thing that he regrets every single day
for the rest of his life which he
constantly tells me and those but these
are the mistakes men make
what impact did that have on your mother
at the time I was heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking it's a kid
growing up it's not nice meat watching
your mother cry herself to sleep at
night
and the other things that go on in life
is heartbreaking very very tough and
you'd only understand out of it is when
you look back as an older is a grown ass
man you realize how tough and hard it
really is so heartbreaking yeah
getting to see the impact of like
infidelity in your own home has impacted
what you're like as a man with your
oh that's deep I've never been asked to
questions like this but it's all good
yes it does add a life where a Charming
best
to learn from others mistakes and not
just my own
so
I would never ever in a million years
have an affair ain't nothing just not
going on not a chance
things sit with me and I'll say I try my
best to learn from other people's
mistakes but yeah growing up in that
period at the time and that part of my
life was very very difficult
and you just you have to learn to adapt
so then at that stage
yeah how your home's broken
and my friends then become me family me
closest friends that the five or six was
like all go to school together they
become my best friends and they become
me brothers from there running and you
learn to cope with life and do things
just cause me that don't worry don't he
didn't detract anything from as a father
he was a brilliant father he's being my
greatest supporter since the day I was
born I'm as Shannon like he believes in
me like no one else could ever believe
in me like he adores me I know he does
and I adore them I would do anything for
me father but yeah them them years when
he's gone very very difficult especially
when he goes to prison as well so that's
hard as well
you mentioned um you're finding out that
your brother was gay being a pivotal
moment why we always had the other other
conscious thought that he was because me
Builder's gay he's he's not
he's not like yes hi the way you hear my
brother before you see him you know he's
out there he really is so we knew it
quite early on but as I say as time goes
on and you see the environment that he's
raised up and he's constantly around
women and and yeah he just adapts and we
see where it's going but
as a family we understand that now we
get him I love means my little brother
but then for the outside world it
doesn't go down well yeah in the air in
the mid 90s it wasn't cool to be gay and
black like maybe just darker than me so
he's the same shade as you uh our Liam
and that just didn't go down well yeah
licked on in school regularly in the
Junior School it's not too bad it's okay
because it's kind of just looked at us
being loud and you're out there when you
start getting towards senior School
level it's like oh okay he's gay
and then that comes at problems and
headaches and when you've raised in
waverty
being a kid growing up I think I seen
one gay man one gay black man his name
was Skippy no one would mess with him
because he was like six foot three and
his name was escaping he would [ __ ]
around the normal swim will just leave
him alone because anyone who did try
mastering me he was going to smack them
but my little brother wasn't that way
inclined at that age he's not smacking
no one he'd just take a slap or whatever
so I couldn't allow that to happen
though anyone who would slap Jim I would
step to them and it would always be me
when every single time
so you find yourself defending him a lot
because lots of times lots of times I
mean the amount of times I'd have to go
up to the school remember being a kid
Taking Me Mum's Car she was away she was
on holiday
and I got a phone call saying your
brother's been threatened to be beat up
from after school or some kid threatened
them so at this time I think I was 16
took my mum's car which I shouldn't have
done uh went and got my little brother
and
the moment I think I smug someone to
school or the other was waiting for him
I'd give them a good beating driving
back home after the young crash my mum's
car really yeah and then for the other
ones ever did that story yeah crashed
the moon's car into a taxi and then and
then set off running for a couple of
weeks so yeah for a couple of weeks yeah
I was gone for a couple of weeks
back in the day so yeah you could just
go missing in them days and uh the emu's
car was classed has been stolen and
stuff like that so yeah lots of crazy
things I've done and and experienced in
my life but yeah that's the first time
I've actually spoke about that side so
you're the first world done you've
dragged something up here something new
oh yeah I'm just so genuinely curious
because much of my
the reasoning behind my questioning is
to really try and understand how someone
came to be who they are today and all of
these like threads through your life of
like the absence of your father which
creates this void where you almost
become the man of the house and then
you've got this thing you need to defend
in your brother and and even the race
thing I find really interesting because
your mother is the same skin tone as me
roughly isn't she yeah maybe a bit
darker yeah similar to you yes but you
you're like you're significantly lighter
than me yes so having a mother who is
can I I'm guessing could considers
herself to be a black woman she's black
yeah yeah and growing up in that
environment where there wasn't
a huge a huge amount of black people did
you find yours I was wondering this when
I was reading about your story did you
find yourself almost like
a little bit
like identifying with that Community
while also not being considered part of
it by do you know what I mean yeah of
course so you're not blocking up for the
brothers and you're not wise enough for
the white people so yeah I've got that
since I was a kid but it doesn't bother
me in the slightest it it did growing up
because you're trying to think who would
relate to what they relate to avoids
just being a decent person I try and do
the right thing I've done enough bad
things in my life
to
to know that I'm a good person if that
makes sense so yeah after
race color creed it doesn't really
bother me you know the good or you're
bad but yeah it's not hard for us I've
always wondered
what it must have been like my mother
growing up
because that must have been very
difficult especially for you know I I
know it was difficult for me mother and
father to be together when they first
got together because my father's coming
into a period at the time where the
chocolate right to happen and for a
white man
with you know a black woman and black
kids and stuff it you know he's had this
fights regarding that as well but for me
mother must have been horrific at times
must have really been hard so
she's strong she's a strong woman and
she she can get through anything
I saw that like my mom obviously my
dad's white my mum's from Nigeria so
okay my mum we moved to Cornwall right
where everyone's white when I'm like one
or two years old and my mum she just
constantly get like struggled with it
her car being burnt by people by people
locally Shop's been broken into
everything and she she really built a a
huge amount of I don't know anger and
resentment towards people which I'm
really happy I didn't carry with me but
you know at that age even I had racism
yeah a lot of racism on the playground
and stuff like that and being someone
who wouldn't necessarily be a target of
that racism yeah but would be could
identify with the community because your
mother's black was that ever like a a
thing where you would hear people would
have the guts to be racist around you
but they but because they wouldn't think
you'd be offended by it but did you
almost give you advice on how to get
through that or never just working out
no never I mean I got a few I'm probably
the only significant fights I ever got
in with someone calling me the n-word in
school yeah and I was the only black
chemical like there was an obviously
Cornwall like yeah night night too
um that was those were the only fights I
ever got into and I didn't really know
what it meant I didn't even know I was
black until someone called me them which
I mean it was yeah so but did you get
some advice on that was no I wasn't
given advice I just found myself I used
to build a bit of a protective wall
around myself so I would let people know
I was half black within literally the
first couple of minutes of meeting them
so that way it would Shield them from
saying because if someone says a race is
coming in front of me I'm gonna smack
you or I'm gonna do something so I'm
gonna bought you a smack here I'm gonna
give you a piece of me man I'm gonna do
something
so I I find myself like meeting people
not be like yes I'm mixed race so yeah
my mom's blocked me that's white and and
some of them used to look at me just to
say why is he telling us that and I
think because I just don't want to hear
the comments that I'm used to hearing of
this word that word I've heard them on
my life and people would make smart-ass
jokes and
this the you know degrade black people
or whether it would be I've had every
single word and phrase you can possibly
imagine and and I would and I would only
hear them because they were undertone
racism it would be said because they
thought I was white yeah yeah and that
was the most frustrating part so then I
felt myself
letting people know look I'm not white
I'm not black and I'm not white but I'm
I'm just me but yeah that let people
know what I was pretty much straight
away because if I hear that undertone or
I hear that slight comments or dig
I'm gonna respond unless it's a woman
and a couple of times I've had to let
that go and it's been women who've made
undertone comments only once I think I
took her up with a woman because I was
working in the sports Centerville city
council and a woman yeah I said the M
with and I was furious and I just
started to give it a piece of my mind
and I called it every slot and sweat you
can go on and uh yeah and I actually
lost my job for that yeah because yeah
Santa once if I was she just denied she
said it but I was like you know I'm such
a quiet not quiet but I'm such a I treat
people Everyone with respect everyone
and meet it doesn't matter whether you
can be anything in life I'm not better
than anyone whether it's a [ __ ] big
man on the street whether they're tough
one I was a lifeguard whether it's a
it's someone who's begging on the seat I
am no better than them but believe you
me they're not better than me you
shouldn't disrespect anyone so yeah I
gave it a piece of Mind lost me job and
that was the end of that you learn to
deal with moments like that and as I say
in the environment I'm raised in
I've found a way of shielding myself
protecting myself and then also uh my
actions and I'll speak louder than me
words because of what I've what I've
done with my career
when I sat here with Eddie Hearn um it
became really Tran uh apparent that many
of the successful people I meet
start with this kind of innate desire to
please a parent Eddie's one of them
right he kind of lived in Barry hands
Shadow you've spoke a lot of people wow
but he was he was when I was reading
your story I saw the same thing you had
this real strong desire to impress your
father I'm wondering why why because
he's my dad and I adore me that I love
him yeah
not everyone has that though yeah
because not everyone has a father and
I'm very fortunate that I do yet he
might not have been living at home from
the age of 10 but he's still my father
and he still loves me and adores me I
know he does my dad will do anything for
his kids
he would literally die for all of his
children
and and that was passed over to me I
think that's
why I adore me kids so much
but I always wanted to impress him why
dad
so yeah he is me the other one I want to
apart he wants to impress him and a part
of me wants to do more than he's done
do better I wanna I wanna I wanna
impress them but I also wanna
Go fail than where he's gone and yeah I
was lucky enough for fortunes not to be
able to do it especially I mean my dad
was a hard mommy my dad can fight you
know really really fight but
he tried the boxing didn't stick at it
didn't go right and it didn't go right
because not because he's not hard enough
for Tough Enough Just because he's
mentally he can't stick with it he can't
take someone jabbing the face off him
because you know he goes Nazi attacks
him with a stool in the second fight uh
he's got a wicked temper you would never
know that as as his children but I've
seen it literally because I've worked on
nightclub those of them I've strapped up
a bulletproof vest at the age of 19 but
and we've been working side by side
working on nightclub so as a young kid I
just wanted to be like him so when I
realized what my dad was he was a he
owned the night club security company
and
he ran them doors brilliantly you know
the nightlife in our city was fantastic
we had the best club in the city people
still talk about today it was called
society and the the policy was three to
one with women to men
though you can possibly imagine the
trouble that would cause and what we
would get from the outside in uh
and we created an environment and a
place that was unbelievable and I've
watched my dad go through so many
problems and fights and things like that
whether he's been threatened to be shot
as house blown up ran over shot stabbed
every possible thing you can imagine
jailed twice
so yeah I just wanted to impress him so
the first step was working on the door
with him well now the first step was
going into the boxing gym that was the
first step
once I found out he that he couldn't
progress any further boxing I thought
okay I'll show you how I can I'll have a
go and it started off as just a bit of a
macho thing I'll show you this I'll show
you that because ultimately I didn't
really want a box I wanted to play
football I don't have a football club
and I wanted to be a professional
footballer but that's just a pipe dream
but at the ages of 12 to 16 you think
you can do it and I was a big believer
in my own beliefs so I thought if I work
hard then if I can do I've always
synchronized working hard with getting
to the end goal I'll get there no matter
how hard it is or how big the task looks
if I work hard enough I'll get there but
that just wasn't the case with football
unlucky for me yeah but with boxing
I always watched it with my dad from
afar I wasn't its biggest fan but I
studied and watched because I was
intrigued by and then upon finding out
my dad couldn't stick I didn't do it I
thought okay I'll have a go with this
and I was just insanely
good luck punching people and that was
from an early age I knew just straight
away he took me on pads I kickboxed the
first
got to a good level at that good
standard and then knocked a couple of
upons over punches in the face but I was
only a kid at this age that shouldn't
happen dropped one and flattened the
other one uh got disqualified for both
contests because it was supposed to be
semi contact supposed to tap each other
for the point and then point for you you
go away let's fight again point for you
and you get to like 11 points and you've
won I think it was 11 points
and uh
it was like oh you can't do this and at
this stage it was me father who taught
me how to punch he showed me the correct
way if I was tearing you fist over I was
exchanger by the way from then the full
to the end of your fist and at 12 13
years old that's a powerful tool to show
a kid but I've seen how proud he was the
minister knocked them kids out of the
kickboxing even though I got
disqualified and lost
I knocked these kids out with punches
and he was extremely proud and I was
like oh this is the way forward and and
even though
I didn't know that then mentally and
subconsciously I've took that on board
seeing how much he's praised me said how
much he's give me for doing it and I
thought that's the way so I keep
flitting and I'm messing around with
that thought and then ultimately I end
up in a boxing gym basically trying to
impress me that I'm not gonna lie that's
the that was the first reasons for going
into a boxing gym and amateur boxing gym
and doing
first time before that was born first
time before you were born and then the
second time when you were roughly around
I think I was 14 15 14 14 15 Yes
somewhere there were thereabouts I'll
have to go back in the years but around
roughly that age what's that like when
you find out that your father someone
you you admire so much is going to this
place called jail where he's going to be
locked that's tough
I agreed with everything he don't so at
this age now it's right so someone stole
his money so meet at this stage meet Dad
owns a puppy he's I say he's running a
security firm he's got a pub on the side
he's got his other job with deprivation
he's got so many things going on
this Pub
uh I think the guy stole 10 000 pounds
off the safe
the manager he was employing to manage
took ten thousand pound off the safe and
went running with his money so uh me
father
pick them up
found this home and demanded this money
back
and the that that was told and no so it
makes another phone call leaves a
voicemail unbelievable leaves a
voicemail of what will happen if he
doesn't get his ten thousand pounds and
that voicemail sends him to prison
so yeah
if someone stole ten thousand pounds
from me I'm not leaving a voicemail like
but you know I mean you know no one's
taking me kids money so and I know I get
these these things from him so you know
no one can steal from me and take your
child's money because I don't look at my
money as being my money anymore I look
at it to the kids
and and I'm pretty sure that's how he
looked it is
so yeah he done what he'd done and then
he goes off and I go and visit him and
then that's when I think another pivotal
moment in my life going to visit me dad
in the big house is is very very tough
but sticks with me once again it's a
part of me life whether things to myself
wow I can never come here he tells me
the most important one of the most
important phrases he ever told me in
life I'm sitting with him
and I'm on a visit in order this partner
who takes me up to the visit he takes me
there and
he says to me you see a lot of people
glorify jail you see Lads and then like
I've done jail I've done this I've done
that my father was the only person I
seen
say what he said to me and I've never
seen it said since I've got friends who
are in jail I've grown up with Lads from
jail and stuff like that so and he says
to me son don't ever come here and I
said I'm not gonna do so could you see
this place it's the house of failure
everyone in his failed there's no
winners in here there's no great people
in there if you're any you've failed
and it sat with me forever
just it's always sat with me so there's
various things that I've done that I'm
not proud of there's various things that
if I would have been call forward I
would have been in jail but it didn't uh
and at the same time I'm very grateful
for the words that he said because he
stuck with me forever
I actually have got
friends do in life I've seen friends you
know being in jail for longest periods
of time I've visited from recently
and uh and we speak to him and I told
him the phrase my dad said and this this
friend the man has done hasn't done a
long time in jail and he said to me your
dad was spot on
and he's sitting there he's been nearly
16 years he's getting old soon and
that's what he said to me he said you'd
have the spots on he couldn't be he
couldn't be any more truthful and
couldn't be phrased any better if you're
in jail you've failed
so no one should glorify jail no one
should put a badge of honor on it
there's nothing glorious about sitting
in the prison cell nothing at all so but
I'm not stupid enough to think that that
couldn't have been me Could Have Been Me
with the cards and dealt with could have
very very easily been me I'm just very
fortunate that didn't happen to me
when you
amateur boxing career starts are you
still being tempted by those kind of
Temptations you talk a little bit about
that in here yeah Street Life Street
Life yeah definitely because there's no
other way to end I've got no
qualifications I've been expelled from
school for fighting right yep for
fighting for smashing someone's face in
but while he was stabbing me in the head
of a compass
so yeah it's uh but these are this is
the life that you know you just it's not
it's looked at as normal I know when you
look back now it's frightening to think
that like if someone stabbed my son had
to accomplish wow it's truly frightening
but it it didn't detail me or bother me
at all
crazy I had walked or two and watched
them hold the compass and I knew I only
had fists but I didn't
it didn't intimidate me didn't scare me
and yeah
when you get explored from school at 15
what do you think you're going to become
in your life is it we still thinking you
might well at 15 you what's the Hope
yeah this one said what you're going to
be when you grow up what would the
response have been
at 15 after getting kicked out locked up
you thought that's what help was going
to play off you yeah because I know I
wanted nice things at that at the age of
15 16 I always know I wanted nicer
things
and I just at that stage especially
being exposed from school I had no idea
I was going to get them
why did you want nice things why was
that simple because I read throughout
your story about these nice things I
just want nice things you just want so
the nice things that I looked at was
like
as a kid the only way I can't believe I
weighed so I've got a gold chain I
bought this chain now the only reason I
have this is because I wanted that as a
child and I've never grown up it's the
one thing I once I thought like if I can
get that I've cracked it I don't wear a
chain out on me I'll meet up and show
this and all that that's not me now but
as a kid growing up I thought that was
going to be me the chain out and the
cross and the Downs you know you've
grown up in similar environments and
that's what you want but I get it
because in my mind I think I got the
things I wanted but I've worked hard and
I've done it the right way
thinking I'll do it the wrong way as
well and and that that that's once again
where the touch upon being a product of
your environment because everybody else
is doing it anybody else who had nice
things where I'm from everyone was
selling drugs there's no other way to
get nice things no one where I'm from I
I didn't ever see a doctor where I'm
from I didn't see a solicitor when I
mean the first time I found out what a
solicitor was it was because a lot he
crashed into our bus on our way to
school my mother took me to meet him
was it's not so crazy it tells you so
much about what's wrong with yes Society
Society right
High School Netherland School in
Liverpool I know where it is but I
didn't live anywhere I went to a place
called chill water comp I went
undercover in litherland as a teacher
did you read a TV show so little in
school that's a prominently white area
yeah yeah it's the North End is it a
referee because it felt it's not it's
enough it's actually nice really it's a
nice part of the Liverpool you would say
litherlands really nice really yeah
that's really really they were like the
lowest ranked on offset or whatever but
I remember a kid there in the school
Steve I went to his house but Brown when
he thinks I'm a teacher and he goes he
goes he goes I think I want to be a
millionaire when I grow up but there's
just no millionaires around here I've
never met any and um he goes he goes
it's hard to be something that you can't
see and I always remember him saying
that
and again that speaks to much of the
problem in society where those kids
don't have Role Models so they can only
aspire to and we it's a big part of the
show we did the what do they call it the
networks of people getting young kids
from schools to deal drugs
bloody name of it but so what ends up
happening is these adults from out of
town message these kids from Liverpool
on Instagram and say listen you can make
some like 50 Quid if you just move these
drugs for me and then they end up going
through that path which
the cycle of deprivation yeah and that's
how it starts but you you also have to
understand that in them areas like I've
just touched on no one was coming from
my area and was going to be
like it's only since I've grown up and
I've realized so three of us got
expelled from school there was me tinker
and Walker three of us are permanently
expelled uh now them three people the
meeting can walk out Tinker is one of
the lead professors in Leeds University
to expel the same as me
walks is
one of the best journalists in the whole
of the country for sports boy knows
everything about football boxing the
only reason he knows everything about
boxing is because the dope didn't like
the fact that anymore about boxing them
so he starts to study the unboxing which
is insane uh and then there's me and
we're we're I say with best friends who
grew up then there was Neil there was
danzy he was a footballer he was set out
from the start he's amazing is always
going to be a football he was just
unbelievably gifted so between the four
of us there
growing up within two miles of each
other
no one from them areas I'd ever seen
before or heard of before me I'd ever
come a professor an amazing journalist
professional footballer and then a
professional fighter World Champion and
we were Four Lads who all went to school
together
the closest of friends and that that
that's just thought out about the eight
of us uh
the others have good jobs and stuff like
that and they've cracked on without just
finding they'll figure out the way in
life but yeah that that wasn't available
to us as kids because as I say
if I could tell you what that Professor
was doing now as 15 you wouldn't believe
me if I could tell you what the 16 year
old was doing and what was going on as
the jailent you wouldn't believe it it's
only the football allows was I could say
he was the he was the the goal we all
aspire to be as kids because he was so
driven Neil was just he'd worked so hard
when every spare minutes he got he was
kicking a ball against the wall uh he
was training he was working he was
playing for Liverpool he was just
unbelievably gifted and but worked so
hard with the talent that He had whereas
others didn't and I'd say for me growing
up it was like everyone who had nice
things was selling drugs
and that's all you could really see
because if I had the seen a footballer
from where I'm from if I had a scene a
professional world champion boxer or
another scene I really educated in your
man living where I was then I I might
have thought I can do that but you don't
you just don't see so I go to schools to
these sometimes now and I try and talk
to these kids and explain to them I
don't feel comfortable going to places
so I got invited to Oxford and Cambridge
and I didn't go I said no and I just
said I don't feel what am I going to say
to people who've Got Brains the Pat the
size of this and they were like that do
you understand that's not about it's
what you've tapped into up here yourself
to make work for you I said yeah but I
can't I'm not comfortable going on so
I'm not going but I can walk into any
school where I'm from and have a chat to
them kids because I am them kids I've
been where they've been I can relate to
them and I just need to get across to
them so I do that now with the program
then do with the weapons down gloves up
and certain amount of it's in the book
But ultimately it's just a it's hard to
get across to the kids in the areas that
I'm from it really is because there is
no way out and I understand there's
nowhere else I was there I was where you
once was with no way out with no hope no
job
Jack spelled from school and you just
think what am I gonna do
so yeah it's tough difficult
we talked a little bit about your father
there the other
um man in your life that you referred to
as being a father figure is in chapter
two which is Jimmy yes who is the guy
who is your I believe your amateur coach
yes he was you know it's so blatantly
obvious from reading chapter two that he
had a profound influence on you
definitely in the short space on time I
was around them and with them I just I
got him and the very first time I met
him I thought I was never gonna work so
the very first time I met him he he
basically just shook me off and thought
I'm not gonna he obviously seen the town
so I walked in before I actually had an
amateur about I walked in there was on
the ABC
and I started punching a bag this had
been the second gym I tried out
so I went in this gym and they punched a
bag and he comes have you ever boxed
before I said no I've never boxed he
said don't tell lies he said how many
belts have you had I said I've never had
a bout in my life he said kids who have
never had the boat don't hit a bag like
you how many bolts have you had to set
up had no boats I said but when can I
have about
to that smart ass comment from me he
replied you don't tell me boy when
you're gonna box I tell you he had about
12 to 18 months and I was like okay yeah
walked on the gym and never came back I
went and went straight to a place called
Stockbridge JBC that's a guy called Mark
any six weeks later I have my first
damage about and they're all hell but
exclusion I just think that I'm I'm the
wave a cheese version of Mike Tyson I'm
smashing people you have to understand
when you first have amateur boats very
very very you'll see a stoppage my first
three amateur fights all London fair in
knockout wins and you you just don't see
that usually a lot of amateur Fighters
lose the first fight through nerves and
anxiety and just being petrified it's
normal I've only ever been nervous for
two fights in my whole entire life the
very first ever that much advice I had
and then go to some Park so I've never
been nervous for any other fight
fighting doesn't bother me I I enjoy
like I said before
so I guess the points I get disqualified
to meet temper flares in one in the last
spell to have a stock with JBC guy spit
to me face I bought him as hard as I can
in the middle of the face referee throws
me out
and then go back to rotunda this time
I've now had
four or five belts four boats I go back
to the tournament table between my legs
and go back to Jimmy Albertina after him
telling me it's gonna be 12 18 months
this guy now knows who I am he's seeing
me box he's seen me fight and he's
identified me as a talent I didn't know
that I'm only told that later on in life
because he would never ever gave me an
answer because of this he never once
praised me not to me face anyway it was
only upon him dying that I found out
that he thought I was going to be a
champion
song which is crazy to think that he
could see that because I couldn't see at
that stage but being with him and
spending time with him
he may be believing him so much and
a part of it was because he pushed me to
the levels of work rate that I'd never
seen before that I never thought I was
capable of but how hard we worked in
that gym under this choose a lodge was
as hard as any day that I've had as a
professional it was really tough he
would Demand only the best from you and
I don't know how he's seen the things
he's seen but he did the cat was a
genius it was unbelievable so yeah
losing him was a was the first real loss
ever had in my life I've had lost at
this stage
I think I've lost
I definitely lost my uncle at that stage
which was a bit heartbreaking it was me
Dad's previous partner
in the business and lose my Uncle Jimmy
was hard but I could deal with it it was
a progression he got cancer and he got
slowly slowly died and went away so that
was a bit hard to lose him but uh the
first real tragic lost her address Jimmy
that was hard grief is the worst feel in
the world it's the worst thing ever do
you remember where you were when you got
that call yep Paul Smith phoned me I was
a
Paul phone me and I was just sitting
there and he's and and he was sobbing on
the phone and said whoa what's wrong
where are you and he was just can't he
was crying on the phone I couldn't
understand what he was saying and then I
got the last word he said Jimmy's dead I
said don't be stupid I was with him two
days ago because he Jimmy had a
quadruple bypass
and uh
he gets the quadruple bypass
and he just comes back too soon he
starts training again he had a bevy and
like pizza and food Jimmy was just a
proper man's man uh and yet he came back
too soon so when Paul phones me and
tells me that Jimmy's gone
I just couldn't believe it remember just
breaking down crying taking another card
again with no license and driving
straight to the gym the top Jimmy gave
me I'm sitting at the gym just crying
and crying thinking what are we gonna do
and and as selfish as I am thinking
what's going to happen to me career
because at that stage then being with
Jimmy I then knew I was going to be a
fighter forever once once I had two or
three boats and when we first national
championships and Jimmy was in my corner
I fight in the under 10 novice finals I
fight against the guy with the surname
Mohammed he wins the semi-final 10 nil I
go in and knock him unconscious six
seconds in the final so when we first
have a national title and under 10
novice title cleaned them out in six
seconds still a record of the record
isn't it still a record to this day
and uh
yeah it's at that point then I'm gonna
make me I'm gonna I'm gonna make it as a
fighter after that National final
Victory and I remember running back the
corners of Jimmy and jumping on the
ropes and saying I am the [ __ ] best
fighter you lot will ever see nails and
not only Sports entered in Leeds telling
everyone I am the king of the world I am
the best ever now this is just so
embarrassing when I look back this is a
guy who was in his 10th amateur fight uh
and I was telling people I'm going to be
a world champion and they were and they
must have been like what's going on Getz
jumps down from the a guy I've just
rendered unconscious and he's still
asleep I've jumped down off his corner
of the ropes after scream my head off I
walk back to me corner and I said to
Jimmy Jimmy how good was that it's
amazing wasn't it and he just looked a
man's [ __ ] shite
I thought
just knock someone out six seconds and
his response was
loan build he turns away to the other
coach and just goes
just as a face with a little thumb up I
didn't see that once again you'd have to
look back on the video and see him do it
uh he never gave me praise but then from
what he told
other people like Jimmy when Jimmy Daddy
got carried by six of us
past champions phones
present Champions Paul Smith and Mick
and future Champions who regardless the
future of the gym myself and Paul uh and
I was a future one better man I'd only
been around with the stage for two years
was going to be a future Champion so for
them to to predict that and say
unbelievable he'll stick with me forever
I have a name tattooed on my arm
yeah so all my tattoos means something
so yeah it's a
miss him every single day not many days
go by where I don't think of them yeah
I'm close with his family and I love his
lovely wife Benny and his kids Michael
and James and lovely family they've now
got kids and Jimmy's affected so many
people's lives massive massive parts of
mine I will never ever forget him and I
will never let his name go you know when
I whatever I am I will always take his
name with me
and then you go in and do exactly that
what what um Jimmy predicted
you would do yeah which is crazy I think
when an ABA title but I won three of
them I don't know if he predicted three
I went through the ABA titles a boxing
country go all around the world I have
amazing success as an amateur bearing
man that I've not got the style to be a
good amateur boxer my style was to run
the people unconscious I've never got an
unboxing ring and wanted to beat someone
on points ever well that's a lie one
time I did I got in the ring against a
guy called Danny price and I really
liked Danny I didn't want to hear
something the only time I've ever got
into a fight I didn't want to hurt
someone yeah
Anya one and then I just I'd never
amateur boxing
is about skill and class and it's it's a
proper sport professional boxing is a
brutal horrible business it's not a
sport it's literally a way of life you
don't live professional boxing the way
it needs to be lived you will get found
out every single time and it will leave
you in a bad way amateur boxing was a
beautiful sport I was part of a team I
was in the Thunder ABC I had great
amazing team made out of amazing coaches
understand that these cultures in these
amateur gyms they aren't there for money
because there's no money for them
they're there for the love of the sport
and to help kids that gym has saved more
lives than anyone I've ever been in my
life every boxing gym does amateur gym
and people use this and use the phase oh
this thing saves life it literally does
it save mine it saved numerous Lads I
know when that Jim's lives there's
numerous lives there who have been to
jail uh
numerous slots who have been there who
have been shot stabbed I've shot and
stabbed people uh and it's and that
boxing gym has kept them on the street
now like there was there's so many wars
that have gone on in and around that gym
but when you went in that gym that was
the safest place in the world because no
one would come and knock him and do
anything to anyone because that was the
safety ads when you went in the boxing
gym and that was because of the respect
you had for someone like Jimmy
and that's what he demands that's what
saves areas it's literally you're
policing your own neighborhood
something that has completely gone into
these environments no one cares no more
like there is no hierarchy within a
criminal environment there is no
hierarchy on the street no more because
every kid is out for himself they do not
care that boxing gym demands respect and
no matter who you are or what you've got
you give that respect to that boxing gym
so Jimmy was a massive massive part of
that yeah and yeah we were very
fortunate as all of us to have them
without a meeting would have changed so
many that fights his lives in that place
and in that Community as well I don't
it's not an understatement when I say
save lives he literally did
you said that the coaches that aren't
there to make money but a lot of the
fighters don't ever make good money
unless they get up up near the top of
the sport right and I was I was actually
really surprised to hear in one of the
conversations you had where you said you
hadn't even become a millionaire until
pretty late into your career yeah I've
become a millionaire until I become
followed up called David day yeah when
you think about what you're doing for a
living you you smashing your head up
you're smashing other people's faces up
yeah and it wasn't until you fought
David Haye which was in 2017 right
correct where you you became a
millionaire I remember that fight so
clearly I think suspicion I stayed up
front I don't know I think I stayed up
for it but must have been somewhere in
the world but I remember watching that
fight so clearly and how it played out I
remember every round and the twists and
turns and the emotions surrounding it
all that was madness madness crazy yeah
basically being fighting as a
professional Army life at that stage as
both been fighting as a boxer Army life
and
bear in mind when I go into the engage
David hey I'm British Commonwealth
European world champion I've achieved
everything could possibly come with in
boxing I'm still not a millionaire I'm
topping bills I've thwarted the evidence
football stadium gooderson Park have
defended my world title at the echo
rioska you know I've sold out multiple
venues at this point I've fought on Sky
Box Office multiple times at this stage
and it wasn't because you were spunking
your money at all you were blowing your
money wise with me money I was I was at
this stage
after I've won the world title until
before I fight David Haye I I Don't Own
Me house out right yeah
I've got property one property that a
rent helped me first house
after that I've got the second property
that I've got a mortgage on
that's all I have to be name at that
stage in life
why how does that happen because that's
boxing for you is it boxing yeah yeah
really that's boxing for you that's
professional fighting unless you team
professional with a gold medal there
ain't no money at the start and you've
got a bank how good do you really
believe you are how much do you really
believe in yourself because you've got
to back yourself all the way
so you know after five professional
fights it may hand me left hand foreign
so I'll get an operation on and off the
best sage in the world his name is Mike
Hayton and I didn't even have enough
money to pay for the operation
because I fought in the December
I snapped me handing off me me middle
knuckle here this snaps in half and then
I spend all of the six thousand pound
that I've just earned to give the kids
the best Christmas they can possibly
have
on January the 11th I'm skinned I
haven't got a single penny in the bank
I've got a mortgage to pay I've got kids
to provide for
but everyone thinks from the outside I'm
this board and professional and I've got
loads of money because I've got a new
car and whatever have you and at this
stage I'm still living in my Terrace
House in Old swan in Liverpool but from
the outside looking inside he's on TV
he's fighting if I said to people I earn
six thousand pound the fight of x amount
to lose the promoter extra monster loose
the manager extra monster lose to the
trainer I'm breaking even I'm lucky if
I'm getting out with foreground
three and a half
lucky after I paid the cup man all the
expenses in training very lucky if you
get out with that you definitely don't
clear it because don't forget she wants
haircuts as well the queen
hmrc so you know uh
yeah so very very tough so then you have
to do
extracurricular activities to finance or
more money and provide food on sale for
your kids so it's very bad but I
couldn't expect I know what it's like to
be skinned I know it's like not to have
a penny I felt Financial pressure
it's just frightening frightening thing
and I understand why people do the
things to do no one can tell me nothing
about being skinned or whatever people
say to me now you would know it's like
to be skinned yes you would
I don't know what's like to be skipped
with two kids as well
so it's patchy fine
so you figure a way out and you get
through it
and say oh I'm achieving that I've that
I've done and and had
it was all off the just to maintain that
dream of one day becoming a world
champion the frightening part is imagine
getting to that point in life becoming
world champion all that and then
thinking my wife then says to me and
she's not my wife at the time she still
need bed well she'll always be me bad
yeah I'm saying to her
she comes down I win the world title of
God doesn't Park I'm on a bank holiday
Sunday 29th of May 2016. uh yeah what am
I supposed to show you that as well
that's the Delta win from goodison to
goodness and park that's the Bell to win
I'll watch that now great fight thank
you
thank you so 29th of May 2016.
I've completed the game I've completed
the story The I'm someone in life who's
I've I've seen through me lifelong dream
my dream in life was to fight to go to
some Park you know that was the best I
was ever going to achieve the WBC Tower
goodison Park I've lived I've seen me
dream through
but I wake up on Monday well that's a
lie I didn't wake up I didn't sleep so I
goes down the kitchen on Monday morning
bank holiday Monday I mean Mrs comes
down
she says to me
that's it now you've done it it's time
to stop
and I'm like yeah I've achieved
everything I set out to do and yeah it's
gone well I said but Gail was so
financially far from security that I've
got to keep going
at this stage she now understands
because she used to think boxing was a
game she used to think like as an
amateur she didn't even recognize it was
she was like you've got head guards on
it's it's not even boxing it's just it's
it's basically it's a gamer tick and I
was like [ __ ] sake girl if you only
knew I mean but I had God on you and
give you a job he'll soon have a [ __ ]
different opinion but she's here she
soon lands she soon learns how I lose
the brutalize my body cannibalize my own
body there'd be times when I had come on
from training and not even remember
where I've been
[Music]
this five nights that I've had that I
can't remember anything I've turned up
to Arena's head of 12 now if I come home
and not even known I've had the fight
I've been
I've lost weeks at a time because I've
been dieting so hard my body's just gone
into complete
overdraft I've drove home from Sheffield
multiple occasions and not remember the
single thing of how I've got almond
drove I've been on autopilot and that's
just that's training camp that's life so
she starts to understand that how
dangerous and real it was
as time went on so once I've won the
world title she's like you need to stop
now it's time to just be a dad and I'm
like no it's not it's you know I've got
to financially secure this so then I
made the uh the audacious thing to
Target a man with a pound sign on his
head and the man who had that pound sign
on his head was David Haye the way I
looked today I knew David from way back
from Spartan many years ago when he paid
me uh if you ever seen the the program
Red Dwarf yeah remember H well David had
a pound sign on his head like H Adam Red
Dwarf to me but no one else could see it
it was just me added to the fact I knew
I could beat him I always knew what
because I spotted him 10 15 years
previously after I won that first ABA
title I'm talking about David hire me as
a Spartan partner for one day and
I'd I'd never ever been it's still to
this day it's the hardest I've ever been
hit he hit me so hard with 16 ounce
gloves on the head guard it made me back
like a donkey out of nowhere and it
always stuck with me but I took it I
didn't go down I should have went down I
still don't know since day how I didn't
but I took it said some good shot and I
always remember the look on his face off
how the [ __ ] are you still standing and
that look and then me being able to go
at him and put it on him stuck with me
forever and then me dropping him later
on the Spartan session let me know even
though he said he should give me a
thousand pound David you'll always owe
me that thousand pound
uh if you drop David you've got a
thousand pound in cash I've had them
Buddha's coach at the time I didn't get
it because he said it was just like he
had a hamstring problem that's why he
went down an absolute bollocks I put him
down on one knee he still owes me a
grand
go there
yeah I knew him I actually knew after
that spawn session I'm gonna fight this
man later in my career I told David
Price on the day me and David Price spot
on that day he was he was getting
notified Mark Hobson and I said to David
Price after that session I'm gonna fight
him one day David pressed by him as well
didn't he yeah and David said
David said
what are you on about price he said to
me I said I'm telling you one day I'm
gonna fight that man and I chased him me
holy I knew one day I'd get him one day
and my past will cross I just don't ask
me why I know that I don't know how I
know it
I just knew one day I advise him that
conversation at the kitchen table with
Rachel are you telling her at that point
after you've won that title that you
David Hayes next and that will make
money I didn't tell her he was next I
told her me career is now all about
money it's no longer about my selfish
needs and wanting to become world
champion she knows I'm I can be the most
selfish bastard in the world and I've
done it numerous times to it in life
I've just [ __ ] off listen with me
brother died I left and I [ __ ] off the
training camp I'm the most selfish
bastard you could meet
it's disgusting
but that's me
so I'm not that anymore I'm a different
person than I was then I I change all
the time and I'd like to think I'm not
changing I'm evolving I'm getting better
I'm learning from new mistakes but back
in the day when I was fighting I would
just pack up and leave
so you know I went through the worst
time in my whole entire life at that
stage and I just packed up and [ __ ]
off
so I couldn't do that when we lost
Rachel's brother Ashley that was the
worst had me whole entire life so this
was after you've beaten David that was
after the first time I beat him but yeah
yeah I can just pack up and just go and
then that was because you know why
because I've got a job to do and when I
was fighting it was a job and it was
only until I achieved my goals I've
become world champion that I then it was
a dream before I was world champion I
was chasing a dream and a goal when that
goal was achieved I actually thought
I'm not I I'll leave boxing alone while
I didn't think I'd give it 100
when I became financially secure I then
realized it wasn't a dream it wasn't the
money that I was chasing
I need something to drive me in life
I've only realized that since I've
retired so yeah do you remember that
feeling of looking at your bank account
after that first David Haye fight and
thinking I'm a multi-millionaire um now
and how like what was the feeling
video information I've been waiting for
about eight weeks maybe longer might
have been it might have been 12 weeks
for them for this for the box office
money to come through
but at this stage I already know in my
mind in the back I've now completely
relaxed I've beat David I've had the
crazy results I've now crossed over as
well I'm now uh a public figure like as
a world champion yeah I was known I'd
even done a Rocky movie for [ __ ] sake
before this sold me I crossed over to a
different kind of
set up a group of people are crossed
over to
your average person so your grandmothers
knew me at this stage things like that
that's when you start Fame really kicks
in but after beating David it's now gone
to another level because David's a
crossover star David's a great looking
kid these [ __ ] David hey he takes his
top off he looks a million dollars he's
David then he's just he's the king of
the world
when I beat him
it goes absolutely insane and I'm living
now in a different world but I ain't got
the money to be living the way I'd like
to live right now I've got enough of me
accounts the business has gone well at
this stage in time now after beating
David I've got enough to start buying
properties and building up our property
portfolio for the family and the kids
something I've always planned on doing
but
when Eddie phones me three months later
he goes tomorrow I'm just giving you the
call the box office money's landed he
said and tomorrow you're gonna look in
your bank and get a multi-millionaire
congratulations if anyone deserves it
it's you
the me and had the other backstory
and it's mad to think that I was I could
have walked away from Eddie I didn't
have no I've never had a contract with
at the end I'm probably one of I'm
probably the the highest profile fighter
he's had who's made the most money who's
never had the sign contract with ever
and we dealt on a handshake bear in mind
I was a world champion
with no deal in place I was hot property
I have to go to some Park Victory the
way I've done it and the way I executed
it it was perfect I then defend me world
title and a smashed some guy called BJ
Flawless like no one's ever done him
before I get rid of him and then I get a
phone call offered me 1.6 million pounds
to fight David Haye on BT box office
and I say no
and Eddie tells me on the phone and says
I can't offer you that money you've got
to take it and I said I'm not going to
take it I said be sure hands and we're
going to see this through he says to me
I can't give you that money I ain't got
that kind of money
to give you right now I said I know he
wants to fight me now he's going to deal
with you because David didn't want to
deal with Eddie he didn't like Eddie
yeah and yeah so Loyalty means just as
much to me as well but getting to that
stage I mean life was very very
difficult I can't explain to you how odd
it was I'm believing in yourself backing
yourself
when that phone call came in and at this
stage
I've got a few hundred grand I've got a
very few hundred grand it's cleared I've
paid me taxes I've done stuff like that
but at the time it's in a company so I'm
not really it's all good you can be a
multi-millionaire but it's stuck on a
company
you mean a millionaire
until you've got that money personally
in the taxes payments in your bank which
is very very hard to do that's when
you're the multi-millionaire
so I had to wait a long time to get to
that stage uh but thankfully enough I
did I carried on believing in myself and
show that I can be loyal even when
tested at the most difficult of time
because you can imagine when I've got
that phone call at night and this man's
off me 1.6 million pounds and says to me
I know you don't trust where this
money's coming from but I can have it at
your front door tomorrow
so this man says and believe you me this
man could
I have 1.6 million pounds in a suitcase
at my front door the next day and and I
say no to it and at this time I've got a
wife who's listening to this phone call
with me and she's saying you better have
a [ __ ] good plan or you're going out
the store
because at this stage now I've got three
kids
and I've just knocked back 1.6 million
pounds and I'm basically worth
480 Grand
I'm not in a company by the way as well
and they served me one point I just
quadruples me net worth so I'm Gonna
Knock It Back actually I said this day I
still can't believe I gotta do audacity
to do it but I mean that handshake means
something so we do we agree a deal when
the money comes in the bank
I'm not gonna lie it was
it called when something is the climax
yeah it is
seen it and I had to actually go to a
cash machine say I had I had online
access and I could have done it that way
but I didn't I wanted to go into because
we put the digits in I've got the
numbers
so yeah I wanted to see the actual the
zeros on the other thing and see what it
looked like and uh
it was over well I was a weird I'm
looking for it just didn't no
that's when I realized it wasn't about
money
was thought
this isn't it's not all it's made out to
be I didn't nothing's changed me as a
person nothing's changed in my life
I've still got three hungry kids
I've still got a Wi-Fi door yeah
yeah
not really changes you know how it feels
yeah I know I remember this I had the
same anti-climax feeling I've talked
about on this podcast a million times of
if this wasn't it Steve this is what we
thought we were aiming for and if this
isn't it then what the [ __ ] is it and
why was I doing all this stuff for you
know why was I working hard and being
obsessed it makes me question
why do I keep doing what why do I want
to keep handing I think now I I want to
keep earning for the sake of
I'm trying to pass it on
I tell myself that as well but I think
the insecure Kid Never Dies in you I
think the kid I I still I know he's
telling me now I say to myself now well
I just need to get to
uh nine figures in my bank account and I
go why
like who do I need to show off to no I
don't need to so but I still in me and
then I have I'd never really talk about
this but I have these little moments
where I start looking at Lamborghinis
again just out of the blue like four
times a year and then sometimes it
overflows and I'll send it to like my
manager they'll go what do you think if
I bought this range of this Rolls Royce
or I send it to my girlfriend I go hi
babe um what do you think what are you
[ __ ] oh I'm sorry
it'll be like I woke up again like the
kid took over the control rooms with it
but someone sent me a book
and I've I've actually done well I've
got it on me audiobook and I haven't
done it is it the chimp Paradox he sat
here Steve pieces the author I haven't
read this in Avenues but people have
said to me you should really read it
yeah you should and what you're saying
to me kind of it's the inner chimp is it
yeah it's sort of in the chimp the chimp
brain which is the kind of irrational
impulsive ego it's where your anger and
all of those things yeah so I don't know
why I've just been taught I've got it on
the audible because I don't really read
the books no more actually looking at
them I just listen to them it's changed
a lot of people's lives I absorb it
better has it yeah I only listen to
audiobooks as well and well other than I
actually downloaded your audiobook for
999 and then I was going between both of
them so I was going like I'd read this
and I'd read like chapter two and then
did you understand that okay
yeah I try and I try and slow down if
I'm talking to another scouter it's out
of control no it's always better when
the author narrates it as well but yeah
you should read that books in Paradox if
there's one book which
honestly helps you understand yourself
and you go
[ __ ] told me this 20 years ago about
my own brain it's that with your
relationships why sometimes you're you
argue with your wife how to get control
of those emotional moments it's all
about your chimp like taking over the
brain and Steve Peters who's the author
of the book who is like this brains
scientist who traveled all the way down
from somewhere at the top of the country
just to sit here and tell me about the
chimp thing genius hit that book my
business partner is an alcoholic and was
all had suicide ideation and didn't know
what was out of control with him and he
cites reading that book as the thing
that made him change his life sober it's
mad the way that's just brought that up
yeah because of the way you explain
things yeah it's honestly really and I
actually was reading the SEC so the
author of the gym Paradox wrote like a
second part to it and I was reading it
last week in Bali because I was having a
bit of me and my misses were arguing
about something a little bit and so I
went to the page about emotional control
just to understand why we have these
arguments where we just repeat ourselves
on Cycles yeah and it basically explains
in there that the chimp part of your
brain which is the front your brain it
will continue to do that until it feels
heard so I put the clothes the book and
went back downstairs to my misses and I
went I said to her I said just want to
make sure that you you understand I
completely heard what you're saying and
I repeat it back to what she said she
completely just stopped
because the minute the chin part of your
brain feels like it's understood then it
it's completely pacified but until then
it will just
you know when you Misses it's like yeah
I know that one so it's how to navigate
life yourself and those around you and
it's all the chin part of our brain
causes us a lot of problems but I've got
to read this [ __ ] book yeah I know
you for sure I've just done the biggest
plug in the world for it but that is
brilliant I had a few words to say about
one of my sponsors on this podcast as
the seasons have begun to change so has
my diet and
um right now I'm just going to be
completely honest with you I'm starting
to think a lot about slimming down a
little bit because over the last couple
of probably the last four or five months
my diet has been pretty bad
um and it started to show a little bit
really over the last two months I go to
the gym about 80 percent of the time so
I track it with 10 of my friends in a
WhatsApp group and this tracker online
that we all use together and so one of
the things I'm doing now to reduce my
calorie intake and trying to get back to
being nutritionally complete and all I
eat is I'm having the fuel protein shake
thank you heal for making a product that
I actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one
one of the moments that you talk to her
about you becoming you kind of crossed
over after that David Hay fight one of
the things I will never forget is the
raw emotion that came out of you after
you won that fight
the first one for the second one the
second one I believe yeah this one
actually does because of Ashley's
passing yes that brought me to the core
still does think about it every single
day
yeah that shit's horrible
he was he was like a brother to you and
he yeah he's Rachel's brother oh he's
basically my brother or Rachel's
brothers are my brothers my brothers and
their brothers uh I've known great since
she was nine years old so Ashley's 18
months younger than sort of No nasty
since bloody hell that makes him seven
the first time I met him
uh yeah that was not nice mate
and let's not get me wrong it affects
hair sisters and their brothers and her
mother and their father far more than
could possibly affect me the part that
affects me the most I've I've tried my
best to come to terms with losing Ash
the part that gets me the most
is I see hate my wife
it just it just kills her to the core
like you've got to understand that them
two grown up 18 months a party grow up
basically like twins so she adores them
here doors here they fight the argue
constantly as as siblings and then one
day's here the next day is just gone
and he'd gone on holiday yeah he gone to
be his his best friend's best man he was
just so basically went so worth widen
abroad in the most unruly country in the
world Mexico and just doesn't come home
so yeah patch if I meet I still remember
that they're getting the phone call and
[ __ ] like that yeah
horrible horrible time but there's not
much I can say that that hasn't already
been said just that the waste time meal
I've had it's something that
I'll never truly understand
never
that life could be so unfair
yeah there's just a kid who's innocent a
lovely lovely lad there
do you know what if if that if what if I
could swap play some what happened to
him would happen to me I could off say
well
he's seen his lifelong dream go through
he's lived his life and he's done some
bad [ __ ] too so I can kind of
accepted if it was myself I can't accept
such a kid like that who's just such a
nice
[ __ ] hell just loved life was happy
was always smiling always telling jokes
the life of the party
yeah yeah
it's completely unfair that's why I have
the colored red and the a angel people
think I'm some kind of baseball fan I
couldn't give a [ __ ] about baseball well
and as people will know the red a on me
arm is for Ashley and it's in red
because he was a mad libel fan and
followed them everywhere so people think
I absolutely hate red but I don't know I
actually wear it with a bit of Pride so
yeah just so many things like the kid
looked up to me as well
so yeah hard hard time make losing them
is the hardest thing that's ever
happened in my life better man I've lost
two grandparents
yeah
seeing people dying lots of crazy
scenario situations
yeah
but nothing's ever affected me like that
I was worse than Jimmy I was just
[ __ ]
just here one minute gone the next yeah
gone so
so what can you do
you said that nearly impacted your
relationship with Rachel as well yeah
definitely a big way definitely but that
was a shot over those I mean
I'd hope it bring us closer but I just
don't think my wife will ever get over
it well I know she won't I know she
wants a little brother and especially
when you haven't been given the answers
that we should have been given and
there's there's there is that there is
uncertainties people that could give us
the answers but they won't so yeah
yeah
very very hard I I assuming our breaks
my wife Anna sisters and her sister and
a brother and a mother and father
especially
a child a parent should never bury a
child in any way shape or form that is
the most Hollow and frightening thing
you could possibly imagine losing one of
your children how they got through it
and how they get through it I'll never
know
yeah very hard yeah
I always think of The Selfish things
I've done once again I've just [ __ ]
off to camp
after he died and just because I had to
honor that rematch I gave me where to
fight him again
and I shouldn't have
uh it's a regrepo I found a way to get
through it and navigate through and got
the job done
you regret giving him your word that
you'd fight him or go no I've gone
through with it should never have done
it selfish
but that's me
either
I gave me weight and and when they give
someone your word you've got you've got
it only
when you see you're [ __ ] off the cam
is that like a form of escapism where
you like the [ __ ] off the camp
becomes this distraction where you don't
have to face the game the pain on the
truth and bear in mind I'm definitely
facing the pain because I just climbing
myself to sleep every night that I'm in
Sheffield
every night I climb yourself to sleep
but I know my wife's at home kind of
self-sleep as well my kids are with her
oh yeah I'll do that for three months so
I go to come for 12 weeks at a time 14
weeks for that one because I know how to
lose x amount of weight
uh
yeah you're alone in a hotel room crying
yeah
yeah whole Holiday Inn Express in
Sheffield me the microwave and my iPad
I'll meet you seven yeah
are you sure the pictures once a week as
well on me on and just sit there
sometimes I've tried not pictures of me
on and I've just had a cap on me hold
over and just cried watching films
because I just
it's Michael's I can deal with losing
Ashley I can't deal with see my wife in
pain that I can't change that's the
worst part
still in pain she'll like she she
wouldn't speak to anyone about it she
will she had just bottle it up I thought
one day she could come to terms of but
she can't I know she can't
it's the worst feeling in the world man
it's helpless
so yeah it's tough in one of your
interviews when you're talking about
this you you referenced that phase of
your life I think as being you feeling
like you were depressed is that is
accurate you felt depressed through that
that's what depression feels I I don't
want to tap on that kind of weird
because I feel people use it these days
do they benefit I feel people abuse it
yeah I feel like it's used today as a
contraction part to gain traction or to
people actually aim from money from
saying they're depressed uh
but if that's what Depression was yeah
grind yourself to sleep and not being
able to solve a problem for the life of
you you don't know how to solve it uh
and there's nothing made me happy
nothing
like not not the only time I was ever
happy is when I seen a smile when I seen
her smile and that was very briefly in
that period of time like even now to
start I'm looking to know she's thinking
about it brother
even now we've been past
be five years in August
yeah four or five years in August and I
know she's thinking about him I just
know but I can't change that and that's
the saddest part because as a husband I
should be able to do something about
that but I can't
that's the one thing if you're I'm a
husband I'm a partner I should be able
to be there for it I'm
gonna be the comfort blanket but I can't
I can't change it
so yeah that's hard it's tough
you said she'd never spoken to anyone
about it but have you spoken to anybody
about it no I went on SAS and that's
where I found out I was [ __ ] up so
going on that show
highlight like I've never seen a back so
I don't know what I've done what I've
said some of the things conversations we
had
uh
I don't know but
that's at that point I knew I had a
problem because
I went I'm not sure thinking I've
completed life I've I've seen through me
lifelong dream I've done this and I've
done that I've got what I set out to get
I have [ __ ] hell I'm financially
secure me because he's over I'm retired
I'm supposed to just enjoy getting fat
now and enjoy playing golf and it was on
that show that I realized that I'm not
I'm carrying the burden of what's going
on
and I'm just constantly wanting to make
my wife happy I'm trying to make sense
of how I can fix my wife's situation
that's what I found out on that show
because I was just broken down gradually
and to be face about Middleton it was
his process that that made me realize
that it also made me realize what's
important in life [ __ ] nothing this
is important as what's in the four walls
of my house nothing matters
nothing genuinely matters I've got some
great friends and I love them like
brothers I really do but I'm sorry to
say it doesn't matter
what massages me messaging me kids the
no one in this world actually needs me
or depends on me to the amount that they
need me I put them kids on this plans
I've got a look after them I've got to
give them the best I possibly can
she's my wife I've got to be the best I
can possibly be for there
not an else really matters
not much and being on that show made me
realize that my phone is just a [ __ ]
distraction
don't need to spend all day on my phone
I spend too much time on it as it is but
I'm trying to implement things now when
I go home that phone doesn't need to be
there
I like I'm trying my best to just not to
leave the phone alone in the house it's
very hard to do by the way I'm sure
you'll know that as well but
um I'm trying to implement things
differently in my life and that and that
show helped me see that definitely did
at the start of this conversation you
said when you're talking about your
brother that you you'd to survive you'd
put this kind of protective wall around
yourself yeah and often when I sit here
with I mean Patrice ever is a good
example he grew up in the streets of
France and he put this protective wall
around himself his brother's a drug
dealer and they're overdose and dying in
the house Etc so he puts the shield
around himself to try and survive and
then it's not until his later years at
like 34 years old after he's retired in
his afterlife as you call it in chapter
12 11 of your book um
that he realized that protective shield
is actually it's protected him from his
early years but now it's costing him as
an adult it's meaning that he's not able
to properly connect on an emotional
level he's running from his pain he's
defensive he's got a lot of anger and so
he goes on the journey thanks to his
partner when she turns to him one day
and goes you're not okay and he goes he
gets angry what do you mean I'm not okay
and she says it again she goes you're
not okay what's wrong and then in that
moment at 40 years old he just lets it
down and he says everything from my head
teacher abused me sexually abused me at
school I speak all of these things that
happen in his childhood but I was
wondering when you said that start the
conversation that that Shield you put up
to help you to survive after you finish
boxing
I'm guessing it's not serving you no I
don't
I'll make sense because she's ever now I
always saying I'm happy and stuff like
that he's actually [ __ ] enough yeah
I get it I understand the side and I
understand but then
I feel like I've I've given enough
the same part I'll never give up
like I just won't because I wouldn't I
can give so much I can't give everything
so I'll hope and that could be pain that
could be torment that could be [ __ ]
that's gone on in me earlier life I
don't know but I won't give everything
you say that on the show you say well
you you actually say you'd never write a
book yeah it does yeah because I never
see it I've never seen a psychologist
and I'll never write a book because I
don't want to go back there yeah it's
not that and and I don't want to paint
it out to be any worse than any other
kids because it's enough
get me wrong there's obviously some [ __ ]
there but
yeah it's just what's the point I can't
change the past so you won't speak about
it yeah it's not to really speak about
so just
just says what it is it's been and gone
I can't change it so
there's no point in discussing it like
I went to New York on the weekend and uh
just be as I got to the airport I had a
shitload of [ __ ] just get to the
airports I'm always early I'm never late
for anything I arrived at the airports
yesterday they said they need to test so
I said okay well no one told me I need
to test so okay let's where do I do what
do I do ghost answer says the first
floor
they've now I'm now half an hour away
and I'm not checked in yet from your
flight and I'm at the front of the queue
sitting there waiting for the thing goes
downstairs gets the test done okay now
we've hit another problem there's a
different name on your ticket than there
is on your passport I said okay well
sound
I'm not in control of any of this young
man comes over to me from Virgin and he
says right you've got you've got to beat
your plane in 10 minutes and the gate's
15 minutes away
I said okay sound he says to me can I
just say something he said we get
through this checkout bit and we used to
put all your [ __ ] in the bag and stuff
he said I've never seen anyone so calm
you're gonna miss a flight I said you
want me to tell you something kid I said
why am I going to get stressed out about
things I can't change
I have no imp I can't do anything to
change
if I start shouting and screaming and
blaming the people who are involved in
this it's not going to change the
situation so why would I get worked up
about it and he said wow that was
amazing I've never seen anyone say that
I wish you could tell everyone who comes
on Virgin Airlines that problem and I
was like it's just a part of my life
that I'm in now
so I don't see the point in going
backwards and talking about old stuff
when I can only change what's in front
of me and I can only change what's on my
path by going back I'm only just gonna
lift the can of more pain and hate or
[ __ ] that I've done that's wrong and I
and to be fair I think about enough of
the wrong things I've done or enough of
the bad things that have happened to me
anyway so I don't see what talking about
them would solve if I can just keep
moving on and keep moving forward
I remain in a happy place I'm trying to
remain not happily as much as I can but
life's difficult you know you know
people look at you and think you're the
success story they look at the money
you've got to look at the scenario and
the setup you've got but ultimately
are you happy
and that's all that matters I don't care
if you've got a pound in your bank or
you've got 100 million in your bank are
you happy
and that's all that matters
so all as I'm trying to search for every
day
is that feeling of happy yes I
understand that there's a need for money
I would be a fool if I said I don't work
for money of course I do I've got to get
what I'm with but at the same time I'm a
happy are you happy
yes with the life I've created yes
to a field it's complete no do I have
unhappy days absolutely yes
I'm a happy every single morning when I
wake up no
not at all I don't believe anybody is
and if you are show me your [ __ ]
recipe please because I'll drink it up
but no I'm not forever happy but if I
look at my life and what I've generated
and what I've created
yes I'm happy I'm happy with that but
I'm still striving I'm still pushing
towards goals whether that be where it
goals whether that be I always want to
be better
so that's the problem with me you said
it's not complete no what would be
required to complete it
I don't know
that's that's the frightening part
so I can keep chasing money I can keep
chasing deals I can keep putting things
in place
I can keep looking at that Rolls-Royce
that I could probably buy but I can't
justify because as I said before Allah
is the kids money I ain't spend their
money on keeping the Rolls Royce so that
they're staying in the plan
a
I don't know I don't know what's going
to make me happy
try and just keep getting better at
whatever I'm doing
trying
to keep a working relationship and and a
lifestyle relationship both of them work
in tandem so I can remain happy people
keep also enough time to spend with my
kids and family because ultimately I've
got to work and need something to focus
on I was retired for two years and
basically not aired I've not seen me for
12 months I just enjoy getting fat
and yeah just being one of the lads with
me meet and then I soon realized [ __ ] I
need something to focus on why
because life just
I can't just be at home be a dad and be
a husband and just sit there and get fat
I mean what kind of example am I sent to
me kids
is there a part of it that your life was
so full of adrenaline and not super
addictive that buzz and then I mean
Fighters talk about this a lot and we
Fury's talked about this a lot and then
that struggle of just going back to you
I mean you said it you're not very good
at normal life no I'm not good at that I
can definitely
yeah I'm not good at just being a I
couldn't be a nine to five dad like that
in itself is a [ __ ] great strength
that is an enormous amount of strength
that you give them a pattern on the back
but everyone out there doing nine to
five I've done it I've tried it I've
worked the next I've worked in
a pillow factory I've worked as a
lifeguard I've worked nightclub security
daytime security
I've worked as a laborer
I've done some mad stuff I've done every
possible thing you can imagine I
understand it I've sat in an office I
worked as a trainee accountant so I'd be
best with that
hard nine to five jobs are hard anything
worth doing is hard anything to be the
best at something is very hard this
thing that you said you think you're
kind of looking for to complete you as
you said does it scare you that it might
not even exist it doesn't exist and
that's the frightening part I know it
doesn't exist but that I also understand
the know that no one can feel absolutely
complete
because otherwise we wouldn't
be doing the things we're doing
so the complete the complete person
doesn't exist that's a that's [ __ ]
so that's a fairy tale so you show me a
complete if you can show me I can fully
complete happy person I'll show you a
unicorn
it just doesn't exist but I I'm still
chasing it
well I'd like to think so
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the UK and when we're in La if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
Tony we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest writes a
question for the next guest wow yeah and
I don't read it until I open this book
so
if money were no
issue and completely Unlimited
what would that enable for you
and then they've done a second part to
the question
how would you put it to use to further
your vision so if money were no issue
money was no issue
creative I wonder if they're trying to
create things for me kids that are
passed out so I've always thought about
when I die
so leaving making sure they're safe
would you give them all the money though
what's up that's a [ __ ] big question
would they give them all the money yeah
your kids if I was a billionaire yeah
no
not all of it are you not a bit scared
because you come from the place you come
from
this yes I understand that even though
me Elder son wanted to be the same which
it can never be he would never
understand
uh he likes to think he can because he
was born where he was born and where
he's served the first few years of his
life he's seen us have difficult times
you remember sharing the bedroom with
his brothers he remembers
I can't even say that no he's always had
the best the kids always had the best
even when I didn't have any idea so
yeah
if that if that was entailed
if money was no object if I sent you a
billion right now not that I have it but
if I did I sent you a billion
what changes I have a billion does it
scare you a little bit of thought of
getting a billion
no no
money doesn't money doesn't mean much to
me anymore it's
it's like fame fame is just an
expectation
Fame is just an intrusion of privacy
that's all as it is it it doesn't mean
anything tell people all the time social
media is the biggest problem we're
dealing with because it's showing
everyone the destination and no on the
journey
everyone just sees me no one sees where
you came from no one sees the street
everyone just sees this point up here
and this point down here no one sees
that uphill struggle the fight to get
where you need to get the hours of
determination of work of graft of all
the stuff you put in no one sees that
Journey
and if I could have that money and show
that it would be more than showing
people the journey that's what I would
use that money for show people that you
show everyone that they're capable of
everything I've done
I tell these people all the time I am no
one special guy just stopped me outside
he gave me shook hands with me he said
can I show you something right outside
and I just pulled up outside here this
is fired away I said stop believing I'm
someone special just you know look at
this he just showed me a picture on
social media I have no idea what the
guy's name was but he says look at that
he said there's hope for all five kids
and it was a picture of me after I just
beat up David Haye and it was a picture
of his insulin that was posted months
ago but he showed me and said thank you
so much for your support I appreciate
that now
if I can't show you I can be achieved
and nothing comes that's all I am [ __ ]
him from Liverpool who never gave in who
never gave up and always believed in
himself if I can do it so can everyone
else watching this
thank you Tony really absolute pleasure
honestly really remarkably inspiring and
the thing that I think the mark you left
on me as I watched your journey play out
is that it's possible to be a really
good honest legit person who is
exactly who you think they are when you
see them on screen who's willing to pull
their heart out who doesn't need to
engage in these like [ __ ] talking games
that like David Haye was doing who can
be so real and connect with so many
people because of their like just their
realness and their honesty while also
being this this unbelievable Champion
that was considered thank you an
underdog for so many years and that did
it all so thank you so much it was a
pleasure reading this as well because
thank you your book is as real as you
are um and it's it's as you say from the
guy outside it's an inspiration to so
many young men that need that so thank
you very much just try and be authentic
and be yourself all we can really be I
mean there's no point in pretending to
be anyone else or trying to be something
that you're not because ultimately in
the end your colors will come shining
through and you will see who your
[ __ ] thank you very very much it's
been an absolute episode and a half
coming here senior environment and
finding out about you as well you've
done amazing to come from the background
you've come from so you want you you
should be very proud to yourself oh
thanks man means a diamond from you
thank you pleasure thanks
as you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when I put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made
foreign
[Music]
[Music]